the president's poll numbers and covet
have have dropped is concerned about
that how does a plan to address that
issue specifically because
having people trust his opinion on this
is a big question people follow public
health guidelines
well we think it's more a reflection of
people being sick and tired of covid um
and um tired some of that is a
reflection of people who are vaccinated
being frustrated that there is still a
percentage of the population who are not
vaccinated and that's impacting their
daily lives so degan they blame
everything on covert weren't we just
here the other day with a crime spike
was covered too it's like everything's
covered i mean this is inflation
afghanistan lockdowns taxes i think
there's more than just covenants yeah it
and it's not and it's not the delta
variant actually it's the joe biden
standing in front of the american people
and vilifying the unvaccinated and
telling the vaccinated
you have every right to be angry with
the unvaccinated when if you're
vaccinated you're okay you're you don't
need to be angry at the unvaccinated oh
and it was uh hunter's daddy telling the
american people uh how to raise their
kids at the same time
you have an entire administration
untethered to reality and when they're
caught in an untenable situation their
gut is to just lie lied about
afghanistan over and over and over again
al qaeda gone from afghanistan oh
americans can get to the airport in
kabul if they want our allies are with
us how much more do the american people
have to tolerate you know when a
three-year-old gets caught with his hand
in the cool whip in the refrigerator and
he lies about it that's cute but not
this old coot this commander in chaos
and all his minions lying over and over
to the american people stop acting like
we're stupid
negan you got to stop holding back
ruining the show you just got to let us
know what you feel come on
jess i mean honestly there's a lot going
on here you can track the numbers with
his negative these negative incidents
like after afghanistan his numbers went
down it's clearly not all coveted
no it's a whole breadth of issues that
are going on right now and martha
mentioned in the a block the impact of
inflation where you have 80 of the
country that's concerned about it and
that includes democrats and
a majority of independents uh we talked
about this last week and
i mentioned that what i would do is
actually own slipping poll numbers by
saying
i take responsibility for these
decisions i think net net we're going to
be better off this is a rough period but
i've always been someone that listens to
the public and i'm going to go back and
i'm going to look at my policies to make
sure that they're more in line with what
you want and joe biden won the primary a
huge primary because he was the pole guy
he was the guy who said they don't want
free health care for people who are here
undocumented they don't want to defund
the police etc and that really set him
apart so that opportunity still persists
and on the covet numbers there's
something within it that's more
important i think which is the trust
issue on this and it used to be and this
is i think why biden won the general
election against president trump he was
trusted more to handle this and now
there's not trust in the cdc the fda or
in the biden administration at the same
level and i think that's what's really
hurting him you know to jess's point
jesse when is he going to have that
sister soldier moment like bill clinton
had like biden hasn't had that he hasn't
woken up to the fact that the country
didn't vote for a radical you know lenin
leftist he hasn't had that clinton had
that moment and wound up getting
reelected yeah he might have to shiv
bernie at some point we haven't really
seen any sign that that's going to
happen yet but um don't let him sharpen
a toothbrush no no you know maybe maybe
some cool whip to the face negan but
you're right it was immigration in
afghanistan that drove his numbers down
there in the 30s there and it was the
searing images that people just can't
forget about
now the economy he's underwater with the
economy and that's inflation and that's
the labor shortage his coveted numbers
have deteriorated they've gone from 60
to 50.
so he faces a tough fourth quarter now
because delta could go up but right now
delta's going down that wave that has
hit is going down so that's good news
but if he could put a win on the board
with these two spending deals he's doing
the 3.5 in the infrastructure that could
give him a little momentum going into
the midterms but still this is a weak
wounded guy no political capital
credibility shot independents don't want
to touch this guy hispanics are running
from the hills white males not a chance
yeah i i would uh actually agree with
jen saki to a certain extent and that is
that i do think there's a lot of code
fatigue at this point everybody nobody
expected that delta was going to happen
and so people are sick and tired of it
and i think anybody who was president at
this point would have a little bit of
weakness based on that number however
when we did our poll uh the fox poll and
we asked people what is it that you are
unhappy about with this presidency the
largest amount of people's reason uh 22
i think if i remember correctly was that
they were concerned about his competence
yeah so that that's that's big and then
it was afghanistan i believe next in
line so that is not something that you
can blame another wave of covet that was
unexpected on that's a serious concern
that almost a quarter a quarter of the
people who were polled have yeah they
say the most damaging political
narratives are the ones that change a
pre-existing notion of who you thought
someone was and if biden ran on
competence that's why that's just so
destructive them right now it's not true
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else